liberals are drawing the complete wrong
conclusions from trump getting copied
the one point they seem to be showing is
and they've been talking about this on
twitter on tv news and all these things
they see now that trump has coved now
finally
maybe his supporters will take this
seriously the people who didn't want to
plunge the entire country into a great
depression and shut down everything
and stop people from going to their
families funerals and stop kids from
going to school and stop elective
surgeries and stop important surgeries
that are going to lead to higher
deaths from things like cancer for
instance because treatments were not
being given
while the hospitals were all locked down
for kovid now maybe those awful people
will take this seriously it always comes
back to the masks you know they they're
so obsessed with the masks
the magical cloth mask that nobody wears
correctly that
that is going to protect everybody from
the virus
the liberals seem to think i'll just use
the mask as an example
but it's an example it stands in for all
these other measures too
the liberals seem to think that we
oppose the mask rules
because we don't think that we can get
covid19
in reality we oppose the mask rules
because we know
that we're all going to get covet 19.
liberals think that we oppose the
lockdowns and shutting down school and
ruining everybody's life
because we think that we could we could
never get it but it's the opposite of
that
it's that we know that these policies
that they have put into place
are not sufficient to stop a virus
because no policies have ever been
sufficient to stop
a virus because the public health
experts that they are deferring to those
people themselves are telling us
that these things are not sufficient to
stop the virus dr daniel griffin
at columbia just one public health
expert among many
but in a left-wing outlet he admitted
this he told npr he said
in the studies masks fail
now you're not allowed to say that now
you're not allowed to say that the masks
are not particularly effective
at stopping the virus but listen to why
listen to why
he says in the studies masks fail
people don't use them correctly they
touch the front of it
they adjust it they push it down i mean
you can see you you know this all the
time probably from your personal life
how often are you washing your masks
probably are you watching them every day
are you washing them twice a day or are
you probably not for a lot of people
they have the same dirty mask they shove
it in their pocket when they walk into a
restaurant
they have to put it on when you use a
mask that way when you're touching your
face when you're actually from dr fauci
early on in the
in when he was telling people at that
point not to wear masks because masks
he said were useless against the virus
this is before he changed his mind and
said people should wear masks
but he said that the reason is that you
put the mask on and all of a sudden
you're touching your face a lot more
which actually could undermine the the
effectiveness
of the masks so i'm i'm willing to say
just for the sake of argument let's say
that that the masks could have a 100
effective rate they don't no study shows
they have 100 effective rate not even
close
but let's just say that they did for the
sake of argument
my argument against the masks is not a
scientific argument it's a political
argument
because in order for that 100 effective
rate to to matter
people have to use the masks correctly
which they will not
they simply won't and jake tapper can
cry on cnn all he wants about the mean
old republicans who aren't wearing their
masks right by the way a lot of
democrats aren't wearing their masks
right either
but regardless if your
policy requires people to behave
100 perfectly all of the time that's not
much of a policy at all
that policy this is the classic leftist
mistake
is they're ignoring human nature they
think that they can overcome
human nature if the masks only work in
this utopian world
then the masks don't work and that's
exactly what this this doctor from
colombia is telling npr
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full episode linked in the
description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you